[Música]
nós vamos falar pra vocês de um novo
olhar sobre a relação médico-paciente
atual
esse é um assunto que eu já venho me
dedicando através de um capítulo de
livro de seminários na própria graduação
e têm colocado isso e esse título vocês
vão entender porque ele é importante e
porque eu fiz esse título no sentido de
nós analisarmos o modelo atual do
atendimento médico
vejam nada melhor para se falar de
alguma coisa que você traga é isso para
o mundo real eo mundo réu seria nesse
caso um paciente de 45 anos é que
procura atendimento médico com queixa de
dor precordial dores no tórax sensação
de desmaio a sudorese quer dizer um
excesso de suor é é a sensação de
vertigem isso vinha em surtos e em seis
meses como vocês podem ver ele procurou
um gastroenterologista um
otorrinolaringologista dois
oftalmologistas dois neurologistas cinco
clínicos gerais e 14 atendimentos de
emergência e ele falava pra mim que
nesses atendimentos de emergência ele
geralmente procuravam hospital diferente
daquele que tinha sido atendido porque
isso porque ele achava que ele tinha
alguma coisa e na verdade é o que se
falava pra ele é que ele não tinha nada
tão famoso diagnóstico você não tem nada
esse paciente cansado de ser atendido na
nossa cidade e resolveu sair para um
outro centro e onde infelizmente foi
submetido a um cateterismo cardíaco que
mais uma vez mostrou que ele não tinha
nada eo médico disse para ele que não
adiantava ele procurar mais nada porque
ele não tinha doença é e imagina como
esse paciente ficou hora um paciente com
toda aquela gama de sintomas sintomas
disse que tornava a qualidade de vida
dele extremamente comprometida tanto no
que se refere à parte laboral à parte é
e socialização
e essa imagem do grito do manche
representa bem como esses pacientes que
sofrem e tem esse diagnóstico você não
tem nada
isso chega um ponto que existe uma
agressão velada entre o médico eo
paciente no momento que ele diz não eu
tenho o senhor é que não sabe o que eu
tenho pra o sofrimento que esse paciente
tinha na verdade esse paciente era
portador de transtorno do pânico que é
algo extremamente freqüente e aparece
muito frequentemente nas emergências
cardiológicas porque isso porque o
transtorno do pânico que ele tem sintoma
muito freqüentes na esfera
cardiovascular
é claro que existem outros sintomas mas
sobretudo na esfera cardiovascular por
isso ele procura não atendimento do
especialista em doenças mentais e sim o
cardiologista outro médico porque o
sofrimento é físico é essas doenças
tanto a depressão como transtorno do
pânico eles são seu marido doença da
alma vejam que a depressão hoje é a
segunda causa de falta o trabalho é uma
doença extremamente invalidante e
infelizmente muito mal diagnosticada e
muito maltratada as pessoas imaginam que
depressão se não de tristeza depressão
uma doença sistêmica e rica em sintomas
físicos e faz com que pelo menos 40% das
pessoas que procuram médicos da clínica
geral eles têm depressão infelizmente se
estima que apenas 25 o centro são
diagnosticados por que isso porque na
verdade é uma somatização que seria a
somatização quando eu não consigo
revelar minha dor psíquica falando meu
corpo chora ou seja como a gente vive
numa sociedade que alguns chamam de
euforia perpétua eu sei que se eu falar
do meu sofrimento emocional e se não vai
ser levado muito em consideração entre o
meu corpo chora e chora de várias
maneiras aparecem sintomas em todos os
jogos por isso eles começam a procurar
especialistas
de acordo com os sintomas que aparecem e
esse doente tem um sofrimento grande
porque a própria família própria
sociedade ainda tem um estigma muito
grande em relação às doenças emocionais
então a somatização nada mais é do que
você trazer seu sofrimento por corpo e
com isso é na tentativa de que você seja
escutado eu acho que essas duas telas
mostram claramente isso vejo nessa
primeira tela que também é do manche ele
mostra um quadro em que se vê o amado
seju sendo abandonado pela amada e veja
onde ele coloca a mão ele coloca a mão
sobre o coração era toda a separação e
vejo na outra tela um doente com angina
ou seja aquela dor por falta de oxigênio
no coração e veja onde coloca a mão
então numa linguagem visual angústia
angina confundem até porque elas têm a
mesma raiz grega
isso mostra então porque é que estes
doentes é procuram angustiados procuram
o cardiologista a seu 90 por cento deles
acham que têm doença física e como
doentes são atendidos são atendidos pelo
modelo tradicional modelo tradicional
aquele modelo que está ligado na doença
o modelo tradicional em que eu fui
formado é aquele que vê a doença e não
paciente é aquele que vê os exames há
uma supervalorização das técnicas
complementares e uma tendência a se
utilizar um excesso de medicação e
sobretudo esse modelo negligencia a
parte subjetiva ea subjetividade de cada
pessoa é o que torna a ele o único a
estar doenças podem ser as mesmas mas há
o impacto da doença em cada paciente é
único por isso que um mesmo paciente dos
pacientes com a mesma doença ele virgem
do medo conduta diferente por isso
porque a doença são iguais mas os seres
humanos são diferentes há uma
supervalorização da utilização de exames
complementares
alguns exames por exemplo como esse que
o paciente deixe o cateterismo cardíaco
não são exames completamente é exemplo
de risco então se você utiliza esses
exames em excesso
ao contrário ele sabe além de não ajudar
eles podem atrapalhar trazendo uma série
d
efeitos colaterais também um outro
aspecto desse modelo é exatamente a
super medicação é o que a gente chama
hoje de o ver diagnóstico e over
medicação a medicalização dos sintomas
a maior prova que nós temos hoje a
chamada prevenção quaternária o que
seria prevenção com a plenária é seria
exatamente você trabalhar no sentido de
tratar os efeitos colaterais produzido
pelas drogas em toda a indústria
farmacêutica é interessada no consumo de
drogas
o próprio paciente é influenciado por
isso que na verdade essa tecnologia
traria essa essa verdadeira e sincera de
endeusamento da tecnologia não é só do
médico o paciente também acabou sendo
convencido de que os exames vamos
resolver tudo então há uma inversão de
valores
o médico que na verdade é essencial ele
se tornou um acessório e o passe e o
exame complementar que é acessório se
tornou essencial e esse doente em todos
aqueles sintomas peregrina de médicos e
médio chega um momento que ele pede
socorro e eu trouxe esse livro aí vocês
podem ver quando estava no congresso na
espanha esse livro diz exatamente isso
quando é o diagnóstico seria o sistema
não tem nada ou seja um mesmo médico
espanhol ele verificou que esse paciente
sofrem muito porque ele não são
diagnosticados por que não existe
tomografia da alma não existe
ressonância da alma
na verdade esse é o diagnóstico é dado
pela escuta do paciente e com isso ele
sai à procura de explicações que podem
ser várias e uma das mais comuns é o do
google ele vai o doutor google no
sentido de esclarecer se é o que é que
tem realmente doença já que ele está
convencido de que ele tem doença o
médico que não consegue diagnosticar
nada conta o doutor google mas nessa é
nesse aspecto em particular
como os sintomas são muito específicos
ele não consegue também esclarecimento
então nesse período eu pensei o que está
havendo com tantos pacientes sofrendo
sem diagnóstico tratamento inadequado o
problema é o modelo médio
esse modelo que eu falei pra vocês
anteriormente ele é um modelo que a
relação é entre o médico ea doença e
quando eu tenha relação do médico ea
doença eu parto do princípio que as
doenças são iguais às doenças podem ser
a mesma mas cada paciente é único ora
como eu posso respeitar as
singularidades eu quero tratar doença
como se ela fosse igual igual em
qualquer ser humano
então na verdade o paciente é único e
irrepetível e basicamente a uma
incontornável e alma exatamente que dá à
singularidade desse paciente ou seja o
que nós estamos propondo vamos sair da
medicina da doença para medicina da
pessoa além disso vejo um ser humano
comporta uma verdade paradoxal
ao mesmo tempo que nós aqui somos
semelhante
nós somos extremamente diferente e é
exatamente na percepção dessa diferença
que eu vou a agir para aquele doente
mesmo tendo a mesma doença
diferentemente porque em cada doente é a
doença tem um impacto próprio para
aquela pessoa eu não posso tratar as
pessoas iguais por um algoritmo por
exemplo a medicina às vezes eu sinto que
ela aspira ser uma ciência exata ela
jamais será uma ciência exata ela nasceu
da filosofia e é uma ciência que está
muito mais próxima da ciência humana a
medicina na pessoa nada mais é do que
viu ser humano na sua totalidade que é
um resgate da da medicina e por tatiana
que conseguia ver o ser humano dentro da
sua totalidade ea relação entre médico e
paciente e não em que médico a doença ou
muito menos então médico e o exame
seriam a as vantagens da medicina da
pessoa seria basicamente primeiro ela
não num ignora a a a parte científica é
na verdade ela não trata a doença e
muito menos o exame
ela vê o doente como único e sobretudo
ela traz 11 a possibilidade de
é gratificação emocional que não é só
para o médico é por paciente é o que eu
chamo no caso do médico o salário
espiritual
esse aqui seria um exemplo é um doente é
que se operou
ele fez uma cirurgia de ponte de safena
mas esse doente não conseguiu viver
adequadamente depois da cirurgia porque
desenvolver uma depressão que a gente
chama de pressão de volta ao lar 30 40%
dos pacientes que fazem cirurgia do
coração pelo simbolismo do coração não
existe nenhum órgão no ser humano tem
maior simbolismo do coração
muitas vezes um enfarto do ego é muito
maior do que o fato do coração e quando
eu tratei a depressão há nenhuma outra
consulta perguntei pra ele quantos anos
ele tinha ele disse pra mim que eu tô eu
tenho na verdade só cinco anos porque eu
só comecei a viver há cinco anos quando
fiz o tratamento da depressão
então isso mostra que quando você faz a
medição da pessoa na verdade eu não me
limito a tirar sintomas o que eu quero é
devolver vida e realmente houve isso
desse paciente foi um grande salário
espiritual para mim no sentido de que
aquele leite voltou a viver vejo qual
seria então grande desafio da medicina
da pessoa seria a primeira formação
médica infelizmente no mundo inteiro a
formação ainda é chamada formação
naturalístico em que a relação é muito
fragmentado em relação a cada órgão como
se cada órgão adoecesse
independentemente do primeiro aspecto
seria esse um aspecto fundamental além
da formação médica seria a participação
de todos vocês se vocês não participam
como atitude cidadã no sentido de dizer
essa não é a medicina é que eu quero não
estou satisfeito com essa medicina a um
trabalho recente publicado no lance de
que ele diz o seguinte eles queriam
saber entre os americanos de veja não
era entre os americanos todos não entre
os negros e hispânicos eram sobretudo
descendente de irlandeses de nível
universitário pais nem apenas 18% dos
americanos estão satisfeitos com esse
tipo de atendimento é um atendimento
extremamente tecnológico em verde existe
um encontro médico paciente na maioria
das vezes disse um desencontro médico
paciente
então vejam o que eu queria deixar para
vocês como mensagem toda vez que vocês
procurarem um médico perguntem pra ele
adotou o seu pode me ouvir e eu espero
que sempre essa essa resposta seja sim
porque se essa resposta for sim
significa que vocês vão ter um vínculo e
esse vínculo terapêutico só esse
encontro terá feltro ele já traz um
efeito ansiolítico você não pode entrar
no médio e sai pior do que quem entrou
ele está tendo então o efeito anti o
genérico
então é fundamental que a gente entenda
que a medicina ela se baseia basicamente
na ciência na arte na tecnologia e no
humanismo
o que houve foi que nós tivemos uma
obesidade tecnológica acompanharia de
uma desnutrição humana então competência
técnica sem competência humana é
extremamente perigoso sobretudo quando
nós estamos lidando com seres humanos
vulneráveis todos nós regredimos da
doença e quando nós procuramos o médico
nós queremos além do técnico eu digo que
os alunos na faculdade que a gente tem
uma inflação de de técnicos em uma
deflação de médicos ou seja é encontrar
aquele médico que olha pra você entende
que ali tem um ser humano como ele
afinal de contas eu e você somos fomos
feitos do mesmo bairro
eu estou como médico aqui mas
seguramente um outro momento eu estou
com um paciente então se eu não tem essa
visão eu não voltei a compaixão em
relação ao doente se eu tenho uma
postura de ph deus como alguns têm né
o assistente de deus essa relação não
vai se dar por que esse indivíduo acha
que ele é superior ao cliente já é uma
relação assimétrica de um lado eu tenho
né a saúde e um suposto saber do outro
lado eu tenho uma doença ou não saber se
você não consegue tornar essa relação
mais simétrica é evidente que essa
relação médico paciente será fraturada
então eu peço para vocês que me ajudem
a revolução silenciosa porque é uma
revolução difícil é são poucos os
médicos realmente não é incomodado com
esse modelo é nós somos a a all
inclusive é a habilidade de
conspiradores no sentido de que nós
achamos que não entra um coração no meu
consultório não entra um fígado entre
uma pessoa com a biografia única e que
requer de nós uma relação singular
cada encontro médico paciente é único e
é exatamente por ser o único ele vai
depender de vocês e que se coloque no do
dele que é o treinador dele é o que nós
chamamos de empatia eu seja me coloco na
dor
o tamanho da dor só sabe o dono da dor
né então essas doenças da alma elas
continuam sendo extremamente freqüentes
e em extremamente mal diagnosticadas
então não esqueçam quando procurarem o
médico faça essa pergunta o que na
verdade é um direito de vocês você pode
me ouvir doutor porque quando você outro
doente ele entrega o diagnóstico e isso
traz tanto para o paciente como para o
médico uma gratificação emocional neckel
já traduzir como o salário espiritual
obrigado a vocês eu conto com vocês para
essa revolução silenciosa
[Aplausos]